Twelve things introverts are best at doing
There's somewhat of a negative stereotype around introverts. People say that they're too quiet to have fun or be social..
Well that is a blatant lie.
Just because introverts don't feel comfortable walking into a room full of strangers or making friends with everyone in a room
Doesn't mean they don't like to be fun or social
Introverts have some of the best personality traits. They just usually keep to themselves
Here are just some of the things introverts are great at doing.
Number One: Having Thought Provoking Conversations
Introverts don't like small talk. The whole "How are you?" "Can you believe this weather?" "Did you see the game last night?"
Chitchat is worthless
Due to their disdain for the idle chatter, they're seen by most as unsociable and this is not the case
Introverts want to get straight down to the meat of things. They want to hear your deepest thoughts, your desires, and dreams
None of that "I'm fine. How are you?" talk.
Introverts know that you have a story to tell and they want to hear it. They want to know your opinions and
questions and answers to questions that are infrequently spoken about because of their deep topics
Introverts have a therapist guidance counselor mentality and charisma
causing us to make you feel more comfortable with speaking your mind and soul. This is good for everyone around
Introverts get the satisfaction of having a meaningful conversation with someone without having to fill the empty space with chit chat
And you get a part-time therapist. Someone who will really listen to you and your thoughts
Number Two: Being Effective Sales People
I know what you're thinking. "What? What in the world? An introvert excels at a profession that requires constant visa vie interaction.?"
Yes. Introverts pay attention, care, and are comfortable in familiar situations
So they can be confident in their daily jobs even as salespeople. Being highly cognitive people, introverts take time to fully
understand their product, customer, and outcomes.
From this, introverts are highly prepared for any unexpected events such as objections, crankiness, and touchy questions.
They might not be happy with it
But they can handle it effectively nonetheless.
Number Three: Taking Care of Animals
Introverts love to be swaddled and love and affection by those close to them especially when it's our furry friends
So they do enjoy to return the favor
Introverts are professionals at taking care of animals especially when they do it alone. You need a dog sitter? No problem.
You need someone to take care of your cat while you're away? Enough said.
Introverts have no problem snuggling up next to a dog, cat, bunny, or goldfish and spending a nice day together
They enjoy the company of animals more than humans in most situations
They sympathize with animals. Introverts can calm a troubled pet since they're experienced with calming their own troubled minds.
They have a lot of energy and want to have fun, eat, and get their belly rubbed
But when all is said and done they need their rest
Same, Dog. Same.
Four: Being Observant
Introverts aren't quiet without a purpose. They observe. While you're over there talking about the latest fad or your weird dream last night,
they're listening and watching
They see the way your forehead wrinkles when your grandpa's mentioned, and they notice when there's a new painting hanging up in the office
Introverts spend time watching and memorizing their surroundings and environments
so they feel comfortable enough to interact with them. Who would jump into the darkness without a flashlight?
Introverts prefer to analyze their surroundings rather than focus on biases so that when they finally voice out their misgivings
these should be taken seriously
Introverts are the first to notice anything slightly out of the ordinary
And they're also the ones to be the devil's advocate and notice flaws in ideas and concepts
Introverts usually spend a lot of time thinking about the worst possible situation and how to get of it so trust them
They know what they're talking about
Five: Being Great Leaders
As are many of these points, this one is notably surprising.
How can someone who dislikes abundant social interaction be a great leader when a leader's job is to lead others?
A recent poll shows that not all successful leaders are extroverts
Outgoing individuals use their charisma and spunk to command attention and get things done
while reserved bosses lay low and observe their underlings and always know what's best for them, the person, and the situation.
They never speak just to be heard or because they're the boss. They speak to assist and help others because introverts imagine themselves in quite
every situation just to be prepared. They're careful and attentive,
humble and prepared, and they're comfortable working alone, showing that good leadership isn't always flashy.
So if you ever have a boss that is more on the shy or reserved side
This doesn't mean that he or she dislikes you or thinks they're better than you
It could be that they're an introvert as well and don't have anything to say about your performance since you're doing a good job without them.
Six: Being Great Workers
Alongside being great leaders, introverts also know very well when to take a step back and get the work done.
They're attentive, wholehearted, determined, and motivated to always do their very best.
Since introverts usually don't use their words a quick wit to talk them out of sticky situations
They use their intellectual prowess to provide an answer rather than an excuse. Hand them an extended project, let them work alone in a comfortable
environment, and you'll get incredible results.
Introverts need a little supervision because they're always triple checking
themselves, seeing the flaws in everything and preparing every argument that could be made against their work, and working around it to avoid said
confrontation. These qualities make them effective followers as well, being dedicated to the completion of their
responsibility, provided their solitude is undisturbed.
Seven: Listening To Your Troubles
Have you ever needed to vent, confided in a close friend and felt like they weren't really even listening to you?
That's the opposite of an introvert
Since introverts know how hard it is for them to express their emotions verbally, if a loved one
expresses feelings to them, they will listen hard and well.
Introverts are perfect for when you need a shoulder to cry on or just someone to hear your story.
As said earlier, introverts hate small talk, so if you go straight to the meaty deep talk,
they'll provide an impeccable set of ears and even some incredible advice for you to follow.
Introverts are sensitive to pain, their own and others.
They can tell when you're really upset or when you need to get something off your chest. If a reserved friend
asks you if everything's all right, there's no need to hide behind another "I'm fine. I'm just tired."
Go ahead and tell them what's bothering you. There's no better support than that of an introverted friend
Eight: Counseling
In addition to listening, introverts excel at helping you cope with your worries.
They can easily read people. While others are just listening, an introvert analyzes and interprets the speaker's thoughts, actions,
choice of words, and preconceptions. They can notice little body expressions you don't even realize you're doing.
They can help you pin down exactly what's bothering you and even suggest how to resolve it
Unfortunately, many introverts are familiar with pain and suffering, so they're quite experienced on how to alleviate any emotional pain you're going through.
Furthermore, calming someone down isn't all about talking. It's about understanding and making deep relationships built on trust.
Being empathetic is what introverts do
Having someone there, listening and supporting you in a time of need, is just as comforting as a nice warm
hug which many introverts may often initiate in moments like these.
Nine: Thinking Before Acting
Introverts don't speak quite often, so when they do, every single word was chosen very carefully ahead of time.
Sometimes, due to this, introverts may take a while to get a sentence out,
since they're mentally preparing and rehearsing each word before they say it.
Since introverts take a while to express themselves, many extroverts just ignore them and talk over them.
This can cause introverts to become even more shy so that they don't get ignored again, as this is traumatic and embarrassing.
So if you're introverted friend speaks up, pay close attention, because what he or she has to say is probably important
Ten: Knowing Themselves
We all know that quiet persons have the loudest minds
Introverts spend a lot of time in their own heads. From this, they know themselves pretty well.
Aside from being silent critics, introverts are constantly having inner monologues,
evaluating themselves and their choices in everyday situations
Thus they rarely have any existential crises and can easily figure out their strengths and weaknesses. They know who they are,
what they want, and what is important to them. They might just not tell you all of that information.
You could say that they're silent, but confident.
Eleven: Being A Source Of Wisdom
By nature, introverts love
information, learning, and discovering new things.
They might not be the first to go mountain climbing
But they'll definitely be all over a new NASA discovery. Their minds are constantly
urging for more facts and things to ponder over in the silence of their daily lives.
Not only that, but they use these interesting facts and information to share with others when the time is relevant.
So you never know when your small voiced friend might know the exact answer to your problems after reading about a similar situation months ago.
Twelve: Being A Loyal Friend
Introvert friends will not betray you. They have no reason to.
They would never talk about you behind your back or lie to you in a harmful way
Every secret desire or dream you've ever shared with them will always be safe whether or not the friendship lasts.
Introverts cherish friendships and no matter the circumstances would never betray someone who once confided in them
They value relationships and try hard to keep them, which makes them some of the best friends you will ever have.
Introverts have quite a lot of skills in those quiet little bodies. If you're an extrovert, don't be hesitant to communicate with silent peers.
You'll be surprised at what they're capable of and if you're an introvert, be proud.
You have nothing to feel inferior about, since behind that shyness lies a storm of talents
And that's all from us at Psych2Go. Don't forget to like, comment, and subscribe for more.